here we go the awesome statement let's
just dig into the numbers starting with
perhaps the big one in a way the most
important the state of the economy gross
domestic products here's what was
happening to it back in March 2020 so
before the pandemic it was going up our
pup then of course came the pandemic see
if you can spot it there it is and that
was earlier on this year but things of
course have changed since then the
economy has got weaker the bank of
England's only a few weeks ago thought
that we were basically going to be
flatlining we were in recession then
flatlining here's what the obr the
office of graduate responsibility thinks
have a look at that line it's actually
yes we're in recession but a little bit
more optimistic quite a bit more
optimistic than the bank of England but
there's a bit of bad bad news here at
the same time which is have a look at
that the gap between where we would have
been had there been no pandemic had
things carried on growing is pretty big
and that means we're all less well off
and another way that's manifested is
looking at our household disposable
income the amount of money that really
goes into our pockets for the most part
over the last kind of half century or so
that's the 1950s it was going up each
year we were getting better off but last
time around back in March the obr said
we were heading for the worst year for
this in modern history well here's the
bad news now they've updated those
numbers and have a look on the right
hand side here's the new numbers even
worse in fact it's two of The Worst
Years the two Worst Years in modern
history for household disposable income
utterly miserable stuff I'm afraid
here's what the head of the obr had to
say about it
it wipes out basically eight years of
improvement that we've seen in living
standards here in the UK it means that
for a period inflation is outstripping
Wages uh sort of two to one and people
also can also see it in their energy
bills
so that's the economic story but what
about the fiscal side so basically what
the government is doing well the big
picture is about 55 billion pounds worth
of contractions so so the opposite of
stimulus but that only tells you part of
the story because it's been such a
roller coaster ride let me give you a
sense by looking at one particular year
of the forecast Horizon 2024-25 anything
above the line shows money going out of
the treasury into our pockets anything
below the line as well the opposite and
you can see it used to be negative back
in May then it got slightly more
positive money going out because of the
energy price guarantee then it looked
like we were all going to be doing a lot
better because of the mini budget all
those tax cuts and then came the Autumn
statement where we are now and we're
back to almost where we started so it's
been this yo-yo effect and that's where
we are right now final thing to look at
uh is of course there's taxes as a share
of GDP the tax burden some people call
it now this was heading up back in March
was heading up to one of the highest
levels since the 1940s Liz trust didn't
like that of course Very uh anti-highest
taxes but now Jeremy Hunt has got it
going even higher to the highest level
that we've seen in post-war history look
at that line and that is something in a
sense that he's leaning into uh he's
quite proud to have higher taxes for the
time being because it's repairing the
mess he says in the public finances the
one chart happily I don't have to show
you is Market reaction because so far
that has been pretty subdued which is
something they will be grateful about